now to italy where a heat wave may have
been responsible for the partial
collapse of a glacier that killed at
least seven people thirteen hikers are
still missing the marmalade glacier in
the dolomite mountains has lost a third
of its volume over recent years prime
minister mario draghi says climate to
change has contributed to its
deterioration
rescue efforts have resumed but hopes of
finding survivors are fading
most likely one of the hardest moments
of their lives relatives of the victims
in kanazai northern italy having to
identify their loved ones killed in the
alpine avalanche
one of them sent his parents a picture
from the glacier just moments before it
collapsed
they also
he sent us a smiling picture
look how beautiful it is here
then a so-called sirac broke loose the
200 meter wide ice block triggered an
avalanche of ice rocks and water on the
glacier
it came down on at least two groups of
mountain climbers
climate change researchers say the
disaster is linked to global warming
the past weekend saw record high
temperatures on the glacier and last
winter there was less snowfall than
usual meaning there was only a thin
layer of snow between the glacier and
the heat
the result massive amounts of melt water
had collected beneath the glacier giving
the avalanche such destructive force
the massive amounts of water acted like
a lubricant accelerating it it happened
just so quickly that anyone below
wouldn't have had a chance to get out of
the way if it had been a dry ice
avalanche perhaps they might have stood
a chance
rescue operations are facing extremely
difficult conditions
so far the search has been limited to
overflights by helicopters and drones
due to lingering danger of falling ice
and boulders
volunteers and their dogs have been
retrieved from the glacier
we were met with an almost impossible
task
because there are massive blocks of ice
and rock everywhere
we had to leave because the temperatures
are rising again and we don't want to
risk it
italian prime minister mario draghi
traveled to kanazai to express his
condolences to the families of the
victims
he also looked to the future
we have to take all the necessary
precautions to make sure that what has
happened here can with a high
probability be avoided in the future
a tragedy that came so quickly for the
relatives nothing will ever be again as
it was
let's take a closer look at this with
jonathan bamber who is a professor of
earth observation and glaciology with
england university of bristol and
germany's technical university of munich
welcome to dw he joins us from bristol
so we have this so we have a 200 meter
block of the marmalade glacier breaking
loose triggering and then triggering an
avalanche is that an unusual event
yes i mean
in itself it's unusual um but but
avalanches you know avalanches do happen
all the time this this this one was
exceptional exceptionally in terms of
the volume of ice that it dislodged you
know
one
cubic
meter of ice weighs about a metric ton
so imagine if you have thousands of
cubic meters you've got thousands of
tons of ice you know falling down the
mountain that um you know
hundreds of kilometers an hour so that
that's unusual but um we're seeing
events like this increasingly across the
alps and not just ice avalanches but
rock avalanches as well
and we we've had mario draghi who is
many things but he's not a climate
scientist he he uh reckons that that
this is a result of
a global uh warming uh
is this something that that crossed your
mind well look uh if you warm the planet
you melt ice don't you it's it's it's
not it's not that complicated the warmer
the planet gets the faster ice melts um
and so
um
you know and and the evidence for um
anthrogenic global warming is
incontrovertible we are warming the
planet the planet has warmed by about
1.1 degrees since pre-industrial levels
that's since 1850 and that's going to
increase the amount of melting you get
over glasses in the summer and okay so
if this is going to help more frequently
then um is there anything authorities in
mountain resorts can do to prevent
similar tragedies are they in fact
predictable
um
so
you can do
you can do any activity safely or
recklessly you can cross the road safely
you can cross the road recklessly you
can shut your eyes and not where you're
going or you can you know pay attention
it's exactly the same as being being in
a mountain van and i think there are two
key things that can do this there is
prevention so you can you can warn
people about the hazards you can
actually stop them going in to regions
that are particularly risky particularly
prone at particular time of year and the
authorities across the apps have done
that in the past and you can educate you
can you can
basically make sure that people are
informed about the hazards and that the
risks and how they change with time and
season
and
location and i think those two things
are kind of key in in making sure that
you reduce the risk for the public and
is there any intrinsic danger is there a
bigger danger in the the melting of
these glasses i'm thinking of when we
hear about the melting of arctic ice
shelves and uh which actually
accelerates the heating is the the
melting of these glasses likely to cause
any other problems
well look um across the alps um we rely
on glacial melt water
for
hydropower it's
particularly in switzerland it's a very
important hydropower um
resource and
as as you get increased melting in
summer you get a stronger summer peak it
changes the amount of discharge that
affects hep we use it for water
resources for drinking for irrigation um
those those sorts of utilities are going
to be affected by changes in
uh basic runoff and and a particular
house is something called gloss those
are glacial lake outburst flood events
and that's when you get something called
nice damned lake that forms as as the
ice is melting and um a a lake that is
damned by ice and that that dam um
fails at some point and you get a
massive outburst of melt water
okay thank you uh for that professor
jonathan bamberg glaciologist thank you
thanks